connie the giant slaps that [ __ ] oh
katya the giant attempts to slap the
bartender here the bartender is half
hobbit and very nimble so you're going
to have to roll at 18 or above to hit
20. flip slap that hobbies off yo okay
okay
so you can say as much as you want but
you can't say the name of the celebrity
or any part of their name got it yeah
yeah we got it we got it we've been you
are so good baby we're going down why'd
you start the timeout and be
and
go
okay this guy uh e equals m c squared
albert einstein yes that is correct
easy hello okay this is this is the uh
the uh the terminator oh the uh arnold
schwarzenegger yeah yeah
[Applause]
pretend to be straight but he's really
gay
uh uh he is um excuse me he's living
living la vida loca
me
it's no okay
he's a um
latin pop
star i'm not a latin pop star no you're
not it's not you
he bangs he bangs oh ricky martin
that is correct i wrote that one too
uh greetings adventurers greetings
as you all can see here we have a new
traveler in our ranks uh this is my
cousin tyrell and he will be controlling
the player character
his name is kanye
he's a giant yo oh
uh dear cousin
traditionally uh a giant is not assumed
by a player it is a chaotic evil but i
wanna be a giant
yo all big
oh okay fine
well travelers you are joined on your
adventure today by a
giant named kanye
now when last we left you you were at
the inn of the north star in the town of
isildor how do you begin your adventure
i want to get some [ __ ]
we're the club at esseldor yeah tyrone
this is highly unusual i think the guys
probably just want to go on the quest
town stephen yes
i'd like to join kanye the giant in this
quest
seriously
all right
the two of you enter
the tavern
what do you say kanye the giant orders
alize hmm
says the bar keep
uh i know not of this foreign beverage
of which you speak perhaps you would
enjoy an elded ale no we both want the
alisay alicia does not exist in this
world
connie the giant slaps that [ __ ] oh
katya the giant attempts to slap the
bartender here the bartender is half
hobbit and very nimble so you're going
to have to roll at 18 or above to hit
20. flip slap that hobbies off yo okay
called the cleric would you care to
restrain katya the giant before the
towed guard is called uh i grabbed money
out of the register but golov the cleric
is lawful good this act of thievery
would dishonor his gods hey man the only
guys is money and [ __ ] dude
i accept kanye the giants gods and uh
yeah i i steal some of the money too
you too
okay would you now like to continue your
quest for the lads of kaldahar fellas we
came here for [ __ ] where the [ __ ]
have
all right you see a bevy of well-endowed
wedges
great
i grab them [ __ ] and we all go in my
suv
fine tidy the giant udar the dwarf and
golem the cleric climb into his suv with
their [ __ ] and their ill-gotten gains
and our alize
plus kanye the giant puts his demo cd in
the scene no he doesn't there are no cds
in this world you know what
do whatever you want
all right i guess i'm the dungeon master
now
the eye of odin opens up
[Applause]
16 titties fall out yes
go go look at that
that's
how good is this amazing i know look at
your voice
[Music]
[Applause]
dude you have absolutely mastered this
game well since um
sheila left i've been spending a lot of
time there we go
playing the game
you're doing really good thank you
that's why we're here man
help you get over
her
and
check out this awesome new game you have
yay
you know i left something in another
room um excuse me everyone
yeah
oh he still has the sensors on
i was like him in his room yeah you can
see him that's funny what is he doing
is he is he on his knees does he drop to
his knee oh
no no no no he's probably looking for no
look he's he's crying he's crying oh no
he's just
is he fetal yeah he curled up look at
that he's fetal hey craig buddy
you all right up there oh yeah bob uh um
i'm coming right out
[Music]
oh
here
hey
man you all right yes yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah it's just that my sinuses are
acting up yeah
yeah i um i was just you know i was just
thinking about sheila and you know what
i am totally over her awesome awesome
let's hey
let's get this party started sure yeah
oh
uh
i forgot to get rid of this picture of
sheila excuse me hey maybe leave the
sensor so one of us can play
oh he's dancing he's dancing with a
photo
is he he's doing he's doing this about
is he kissing it guys we don't i think
he's kissing it you know what i'm going
to turn this off cause we don't need to
change it and you die
he's under his buckle look at this his
pants are coming off his pants are
coming off oh god
yeah no no no no no no no no okay that's
happened oh no no no
he's he he's he is totally on the bed
he's totally flat on the bed oh maybe
he's shaking a can of hairspray oh gosh
gross oh
girl
we shouldn't be
okay you know is he reaching down for
his foot i know he likes his foot isn't
it is that
i don't know
and coming back
[Music]
i am sorry everybody
would you like me to make some snacks
wash your hands first
hey man tyrell about to come out here
right now yeah
watch this watch this dude
yo tyrell yo what up lawrence hey man
you want to play front hand backhand i
don't know that game man it's easy dog
all you got to do is say front hand the
backhand all right front hand
bam i got you sucker
[Laughter]
oh okay okay uh i see how it is come on
man come on you know that that's funny
back hand
huh it's still my move right i choose
backhand this time
really
back hand
oh look tom i'm sorry but i ain't sorry
you know what i mean i mean you asked
for it i mean you literally asked for it
right hand
what no why you want a hip got it i
figured it out front hand no backhand
backhand look look dude hey if you want
me to slap you across the face backhand
i'll do it okay don't think i won't do
it but but you know that i'm with you
right i mean there ain't no game code
front hand backhand
oh doc
yeah i get it i get it all right all
right all right
as soon as i get good at front hand back
hand you want to stop playing play what
man i made it up so i can smack you in
the face i'm about to smack you in the
face
as soon as it's my turn bat hat there
ain't no turns because it ain't no game
you ain't got no game backhand
right hand
look i don't know if you [ __ ] with me at
this point or what
but i don't want to
smack it no more
where you going then okay forfeit
four fish i win i went from him back in
okay me and you
me and you me and you
hmm
backhand
oh
[Music]